- I was very nervous. I was like,
I want to say his name right.
I love the German English.
- Yeah. But the last name is like,
- Schweighofer
- Schweighofer is fantastic,
and the last name is
like, even for my family,
sometimes unpronounceable.
(laughs)
- It's like,
- Is that after alcohol is involved?
(laughs)
- Yeah after lot of alcohol, Schweighofer.
Yeah it's like, uh, yeah.
(laughs)
- That's how most Americans sound (laughs)
Well meet Jamie, have
y'all ever met before?
- Very nice to meet you.
- I'm a huge fan of both of
you. And it's like, you know,
it's, it's, it's crazy.
Today was like, everyone in
Germany was like, hug everyone.
It's crazy.
- Aww I love it, I love it
. Army of Thieves looks
great and funny as well.
So did you direct this
one? Is that what I hear?
- Yes, I directed this movie.
Yeah, yeah, because we did
Army of the Dead and then at that time,
it, my character in that film it's
it's its name is Ludwig
Dieter, the safecracker.
And uh
(applause)
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
- Thank you
(laughs)
- I am amazing.
- I am and uh,
yeah and, one day Zack
Snyder called me and said,
Martinez,
we have an idea for a potential
spinoff for the character.
So would you direct the
film? And I said, yes,
but who's the character.
And he said, it's theater.
- Oh my gosh!
- And I said, thank God.
(cheers)
- That's so cool!
- I love the clapping.
- Are you getting recognized
everywhere right now?
- Yeah.
(laughs)
You know, it's,
you know when it's,
when there are Germans involved a lot,
but there, you know, I have a,
there's a restaurant
I love here in, in LA.
And, can I tell the story?
- Yeah.
- When I was, you know,
I was in a restaurant,
I was super relaxed and I had
breakfast and they were like
a group of people looking at me, you know?
And I, and I thought the
Americans they know me,
that's cool.
- Oh my God! This is my moment.
- Yeah, and, so, but after a few seconds
I recognized, okay no they're Germans
and then when they saw me recognizing them
they, they thought like,
"okay let's come over,
let go over there. Can we have
an autograph or a picture"
So I took a picture in front
of all the other Americans in
the cafe, but you watch their
faces like, "who is he?"
(laughs)
Who is this guy?
- I love that!
- They're gonna know soon,
they're gonna know soon.
- I love it though! You find your people
wherever you go though.
I feel it about Texans.
Like I'm from Texas here
and everywhere I go,
even if you don't know
each other, you're like,
you're from Texas. And it's like,
you don't even know each other,
but you're like, "we're so similar."
So wait. So people think,
I heard that people say that you
look like Brienne Of Tarth,
right from Game of Thrones.
Is that what they say?.
- There could be, a lot
of people say that. Yeah.
And it's like, you know.
- I love her.
- Yeah?
- Do you know that she was,
she was top two favorite characters
in that whole series for me.
- Look at first, first I need,
I want to, I need to say,
sorry. Hi from Natalie
Emmanuel because Natalie
Natalie, she, because we know
you're a huge Game of Thrones fan.
- Yes!
- And Natalie was like, "give
her a big kiss and hugs".
- Oh my Gosh! Well,
COVID kiss, COVID kiss.
(laughs)
Why was my mouth open?
That was, that was awkward.
(laughs and claps)
I don't know why I did that.
No, I love that, I love that.
So, do we have, I wanna see a picture
of Brienne Of Tarth,
but here's the thing,
(laughs)
you don't look identical,
but you could be cousins,
you know like, similar looking cousins,
I think so. I think so.
Do you ever get mistaken for anyone?
- Not very often, but my,
I think my wife would like
me to be to be Brad Pitt.
(laughs)
So try that one if you can find it.
- After some, after some drinks,
I think so.
(laughs)
Looks awesome.
I think so. I think so.
(claps)
So what, you also do a
very specific impression.
What is your impression?
- Oh yeah. My impression is, you know,
I don't know if you know, but in Germany,
all the movies from, you know,
around the world are dubbed
So it's like,
- Yeah
- It's, dubbing is big in Germany.
So, and we have, like,
there is a voice for
Eddie Murphy is a very,
it's a very, it's a voice
where, when a German-voice,
when this guy talks on the street,
everyone would say it's Eddie Murphy. So,
- Oh because he does all the Eddie Murphy
- He does all the Eddie Murphy
- They hired the same person.
- The same, and he sounds like, you know,
Eddie Murphy in Germany sounds
like this, like, you know,
like, (speaks German)
and it's like,
(laughs)
and, yes.
- I can't wait to have Eddie
Murphy back on the show
(laughs)
- Yeah
- You should show him now
- If you would, if you
would do that on the street,
when you would say, (speaks german)
Everyone would say, "It's
Eddie Murphy! Oh my God!"
- It's like a Jamaican version.
Well, this is actually our audience.
Warm-up comedian is Ruben
Irvin, and he's amazing,
he used to voice the character of donkey
at Universal Theme Parks,
he's amazing at Eddie Murphy.
So could Ruben give you like
a line and you dub it into
German for us?
- Yes, I can, I can do this.
- Okay, go ahead.
( does Eddie Murphy)
(laughs)
- That's amazing!
- That was, that was pretty fast,
but in Germany would sound like this.
(speaks German)
(laughs)
- I kinda wanna see all
American films in German now.
Well that is what people to be
dubbing then that's awesome!